foreign
[Music]
good morning everyone
it's 8 A.M on a beautiful San Francisco
morning thanks for joining us uh what
better way to start your day than
learning from two Innovative companies
about how to use machine learning at
scale to solve real world problems
my name is Borah I have the pleasure of
being accompanied by two of my
co-presenters Gandalf from Discord which
you'll hear from soon and Daniel from
tamer
I hope our session will have something
relevant to everyone in the room because
we'll go after different use cases so
independent of the industry you're in or
where you are in the ml life cycle or a
growth trajectory
hopefully we'll have something for you
first Tamer will talk about how they
offer a data platform for Enterprises
who are trying to work with data quality
issues especially as they merge data
from disparate sources then we'll have
Discord talking to us about how they
built this machine learning platform for
the data scientists and app developers
where they can more effectively
collaborate and reuse the data and serve
low latency real-time predictions to
their users
I'm sorry okay but before we do that
let's talk about bigtable the database
that is behind a lot of these use cases
that we're about to go through
this clicker is very confusing
Google offers many different databases
some of them are relational databases
some are nosql databases and caches and
depending on uh where you are sometimes
you may want to use third-party engines
in Google cloud like Oracle SQL Server
MySQL Google also has its own databases
that is homegrown and bigtable falls
into that category
and we may say it's one of the most
influential because it was arguably the
database that led to the nosql database
movement uh 18 20 years ago which led to
open source projects that are very
popular today like Apache Cassandra and
hbase they were inspired by a big table
and big table has been in production and
continuous production for the past 15 18
years at Google and it's the database
behind a lot of Google's billing user
plus services like Google analytics ads
search maps YouTube Etc it currently
serves about 6 billion queries per
second
answer uh handles over 10 exabytes of
data
and for the past eight years uh big
table is also available as Cloud
bigtable Google Cloud users and it's
used by some of world's largest Brands
online from social media to streaming to
financial services crypto you name it
so bigtable offers consistent single
digit millisecond latencies and high
read and write throughput and you can
deploy it in a multi-master
multi-primary setup where you could have
clusters across the world in a global
deployment
further reduce the latency is if you're
serving users and you can bring the data
closer to them it helps you reduce the
latencies further as a result of this
it's good for many different use cases
but since we're talking about machine
learning today I'll highlight some that
are immediately relevant to machine
learning
so in the domains of AD Tech retail and
media personalization for example is one
example of this and if you want to learn
more about how this works Google ads
publish the paper on Google Cloud blog
last year which goes into the details of
how they use bigtable for serving ads
personalized ads at scale
across financial services iot and other
areas again future store online feature
store is a very common use case it
serves different use cases like fraud
detection and credit decisioning we also
see a lot of big table usage in iot
Telemetry for stuff like alerting and
predictive maintenance where big table
is high read and write throughput
becomes very handy
and we have even seen use cases where
our users got created with hashing the
row keys and they use bigtable for
things like embedding search near
duplicate detection Etc
so I walk you through some big table use
cases and a quick overview
let's hear from Daniel about how to use
bigtable in production
all right
thank you Borah
hi everybody good morning uh very
excited to be here opening for LL Cool J
uh never never imagined in a million
years that would be happening but here
we are
all right let's see
let's see if I can figure out the
clicker there we go that's my generative
AI right there
my name is Dan I am a co-founder of
Tamer and today I'm going to tell you
about Tamer and bigtable unsurprisingly
and uh and you know we we began to adopt
bigtable along with hbase about five six
years ago
and it's been a huge success story for
us uh from a technical adoption
perspective and our our usage of
bigtable as a system and as a key
component in what we do has has grown
and grown over time
um so it's a fun story let's get into it
uh first let me introduce you to Tamer
and who we are as a company uh Tamer is
the world leader in ml driven data
mastering and data unification
um
we were co-founded uh by you know among
among uh others among myself uh by Mike
Stonebreaker and Andy Palmer
who previously co-founded the company
vertica systems another large-scale uh
uh distributed database and uh uh you
know Mike as you may know is the touring
Award winner for his contributions to
the field of database systems so it goes
without saying that we're folks who know
a good database when we see one uh and
and so so you know that's that's part of
why this is cool
now what we do at Tamer is we take data
which generally speaking is a huge mess
all of the time and we turn it into
something useful we take data and we
apply all sorts of different techniques
to clean it enrich it combine it match
it together so that you can get high
quality outputs that are actually
actionable for a business we do this
within large Enterprises and we do it by
applying machine learning and artificial
intelligence techniques to essentially
deliver results faster at lower expense
and uh and with with just generally
better results than you could achieve
using traditional methods
uh our product and our engine is based
on over a decade of research and
development in this field of applying
machine learning and probabilistic
methods to problems in data integration
and uh
our product bakes all of that in and
presents it in a way where end users can
take advantage without themselves
needing to you know hold a PhD in
machine learning or or neural networks
or anything like that
now uh that's a little bit about Tamer
let's get into uh some of the context of
how how we use bigtable
I'm going to go through
General context for why we chose
bigtable as a system and as kind of a
Cornerstone of our product in the first
place uh and and then I'll get into some
specific highlights of experiences I'm
hoping that kind of that range of
content will appeal to folks who are
completely brand new to bigtable on one
hand as well as to practitioners who
have been playing with it for a long
time
so first of all some high-level
architecture
this is tamer's solution architecture
from 30 000 feet
uh it's fundamentally a very simple
picture on the left hand side you have
Source systems So within a large
Enterprise this is anything that holds
data or generates data so applications
databases API Services whatever
we're going to load all of that data
from these sources into our system
process it improve it in a myriad way a
number of ways and then we're going to
take those improved results and deliver
them to Downstream systems on the right
here so that could be bi tools
applications Services apis AI models
data warehouses you name it
so fundamentally this is a picture of a
pipeline
and you know it's take data from point A
process it make it good put it down in
point B
but the architecture is also in a way a
stateful database
we store results and intermediate
results from these processing pipelines
so that we can support features like
incremental updates so that we can
provide apis and a user interface where
users can come in and interact with the
data and improve the pipeline and the
process as they go and we can also act
as a system of record within a context
of like Master data management so all of
that depends on being able to take this
large mass of data that's kind of
in-flight processing and store it within
a distributed database engine that can
support all the work workloads that we
need
uh looking inside the Box
this is some of our internal
architecture I want to focus really on
the the bottom left corner here which
are the three pillars of what we call
our data plane
so these are Cloud dataproc which
provides distributed processing and
Spark It's bigtable which is our primary
storage for data scale artifacts and
it's bigquery which we use for views and
ad hoc queries that support features
within our user interface
now let's talk about the problem that
we're solving and why it's so critical
to have a highly capable distributed
storage system within it the most
compute intensive problem that we solve
is clustering records matching records
across all these different Source
systems and doing it in a way where we
don't have a join key this is
essentially a fuzzy join where we're
using probabilistic techniques and an
ensemble of models to learn what
constitutes a join uh and you know what
how do we map records from all these
things to the same real world entities
so that's fundamentally an N squared
problem you need to compare every record
to every other record
um algorithmically of course we don't do
all that but if you want to achieve High
recall you really do need to explore a
large portion of that quadratic scale
space to be successful
we do this on data sets that contain
billions of records and that are updated
millions of Times Daily and so we need
to be able to handle processing
workloads that that can apply our our
pipelines at that scale
our system supports sub second ad hoc
matches and updates so that's another
layer that needs to be added into this
so at that scale we need we need a back
end that's extremely performant
so bigtable satisfies all of these
workloads
it it supports the high throughput batch
processing that we need both in terms of
reading and writing data it supports
targeted incremental updates either
within pipelines or via apis and then it
supports low latency interactions and
point queries and all sorts of sorts of
the the good lookups you get from a
highly capable key Value Store
uh but it doesn't just satisfy the the
requirements of our workloads it really
has these major advantages that put it
over the top compared with uh other
systems in you know in the domain
first of all it really sits in this
optimal position in the trade-off space
um thanks to the internal architecture
of bigtable uh and you know this this is
what Bohr was mentioning about why
bigtable kicked off this nosql trend
it's capable of uh maintain uh
essentially write performance and read
performance does not degrade with the
scale of data stored within the system
and that's critical for us because we're
writing huge amounts huge volumes of
data and we need to make sure that the
system doesn't suffer the more that the
the user puts in it
uh another key Advantage is the
elasticity of bigtable you can scale It
Up and Down based on workload it has an
auto scaler built in or you can manually
resize clusters on the Fly
and I'm going to talk for uh first in a
second a little more about how that
gives you free performance but the the
really critical thing just fundamentally
is that allows us to balance batch
workloads with low latency query
workloads and handle both of those
together in a way where we can still
meet our slas
finally as a managed service the total
cost of ownership of bigtable is just
it's like orders of magnitude lower than
running comparable systems yourself we
also support hbase and Cassandra and
bigtable makes things possible on Google
Cloud that are you know simply
Unthinkable on other clouds or operating
on-prem
all right so that that's kind of the
context on why we chose bigtable let's
get into some of the the details of our
experience with it
um just some quick and dirty numbers
this is like a typical customer uh
deployment we're processing about 15
terabytes of data can range between 10
and 20. uh and we're going to have a
background query load of about you know
somewhere between four and eight
thousand queries per second uh targeting
a P99 uh latency of 10 milliseconds uh
which we typically achieve at the scale
with just a small three node cluster so
extremely performant extremely reliable
then customers will run periodic batch
refreshes so let's say like a weekly
refresh of all of the data to
incorporate holistically whatever's
changed
and uh when we do that we'll launch a
spark cluster that's going to do all
this processing back and forth Hammer
the system
and so the system will scale up to let's
say a 30 node maximum and uh and give us
extremely high throughput while still
allowing us to to hit those uh those
latency slas for the the interactive
query load
now uh this I think is is some of the
cloud magic that bigtable brings and and
that that Google services kind of bring
in general
um
uh essentially if uh we extensively use
elastic and ephemeral resources within
Google Cloud so when we run large-scale
pipelines we're going to spin up a
dataproc cluster on the Fly Just for the
the purpose of that pipeline
uh and and we use Auto scaling within
bigtable uh so what what we're able to
achieve so that the chart on the left is
showing run times for clusters of
different sizes and what you can see is
that essentially you know we're
achieving near linear speed up while
we're scaling up the size of uh of the
hardware that we're throwing at these
pipelines
um so that's great it means that the
problem is well parallelized
um what's really remarkable is the chart
on the right though so this is the cost
of the runs for those different size
clusters and what you can see is that
the the cost on the large cluster
is you know within 10 the same as the
cost on the small cluster but it went
three times faster
so it's because we're we're
parallelizing the problem very well
achieving extremely high utilization we
can throw more resources at the problem
solve it faster and then get rid of
those resources and stop paying for them
and so like this is this is some of our
secret sauce like this is amazing
um
last thing I just want to share some
lessons that we've learned from working
closely uh with bigtable uh and these
kinds of use cases
first and I think this is like big table
101 is that key design how you design
your your primary Keys uh is is critical
this is especially true for uh batch
processing use cases if you want to get
good parallelism like we saw on the
previous slide in that linear speed up
uh you need to use key design that's
going to spread the data across the
whole cluster and give you that lift
um if you're doing that one neat trick
that we learned that will speed up your
right throughput by a factor of five is
to sort batch rights this is like
something nuts that that we we sort of
stumbled upon
um this chart here is like mid
experiment like the thing on the left
where it says April 23rd is like without
this trick and then like that Spike
that's off the chart is like we turned
we made a one-line code change and we're
like
holy crap
um so basically if you're hashing your
keys it's going to spray data all over
the cluster if you sort your batches it
reduces overall Network load in the the
service layer and uh amazing things
happen so definitely do that
um finally this is sort of an unexpected
advantage that we discovered as we we
worked closely with bigtable it's an
amazing platform for performance
engineering it comes built in with a
wide set of Tools around observability
metrics and the key analyzer that give
you just an incredible developer
experience so it's great to just dive in
get your hands dirty
and that's it
all right thank you Gandalf take it away
thank you so much didn't know about the
sorting and we might have to do some
work later today
thank you all so much for being here
so let's let's jump in
so first of all I'm very happy to be
here today to talk to talk to you about
how Discord leverages gcp Technologies
specifically bigtable for a future star
my name is Fernandez and I head up the
ml platform team at Discord
uh but first if you're not familiar
familiar with Discord
this could release about giving people
the power to create space to find
belonging in their lives we want to make
it easier for you to talk regularly with
the people that you care about we want
to help you build relationship with
friends and communities even if they're
local or if they're across the globe in
the eight years since we launched we
built up a dedicated user base over 150
million users that interact in over 19
million communities some of our
communities are huge uh you may have
heard of mid-journey for example but
many are small groups of friends
classmates
people who share an obscure hobby I've
come across people who built 1970
synthesizers I've come across people
that are very very particular about the
magic the Gathering rules that they play
they find their communities on this card
so what about machine learning and
Discord
we use machine learning to keep our
users safe
and detect potentially harmful
and abusive content and also to keep
unwanted actors out
we also use machine machine learning to
help keep our users up to date with what
they care about and help them find new
communities
but machine learning is nothing without
data and data is nothing without a fast
reliable and scalable way to get at it
and that's why we're here today to talk
about how we are building our future
start Discord using Google Technologies
uh but before we jump in
what is a feature store
and in case somebody here is not very
familiar with machine learning
a feature is a piece of data that is
used as an input into into either
training a model or once you have
trained them all to make a prediction
to us a feature store is a layer on top
of our existing data warehouse to
present the data in ways that make sense
for machine learning
the feature store makes it easy to
access data for machine learning
training
and abstracts Away the complexities of
where the data is stored of how to and
how to make predictions at real time at
high scale
and also a feature store should make it
really really easy to discover and
understand features
features can be accessed in multiple
ways data scientists they love to use
jupyter notebooks and want to easily
consume them via python
as they build evaluate and iterate on
their models
our backend and machine learning
Engineers need them in real time to make
prediction based on user actions at
Scales when you have tens of millions of
views that are online at the given time
our underlying data warehouse of Discord
is bigquery based
but we don't want our machine learning
Engineers our data scientists to have to
craft complex bigquery joints to get
their data we want they want to have
access to
um
specifically we want to give them an API
that makes it very easy for them to do
time travel
time travel is the ability to access
feature values as they were at a
particular point in time in the past
so you want to say at time T when I'm
looking to make a prediction what are
the values of all the features that I
care about some might have happened
a second beforehand some may have
happened a day beforehand and these
queries can get extremely hairy if you
do them
and if you mess up
you start pulling out data from the
future your machine learning model when
it's in it's going to work really really
well when you put it into production
it's going to work really really badly
and this is uh yeah it sounds funny but
it actually is a real actual problem
when you have data that lines up on
along different time scales so we wanted
to just fully abstract that away
and just gives a user an API saying give
me all the values up to time t for what
I care about
another thing that we see is in machine
learning in general is that a common
common anti-pattern if you don't have a
strong feature store is that each team
or even individuals within a team
will do the exact same feature
engineering they'll recreate the same
data point over and over and over again
they may not they may find even find
something and say well I don't know do I
trust this I'll just I'll just make my
own
um
additionally in a typical data warehouse
the main unit of abstraction is the
table you know we look for we look for a
particular table and we say well but
what are the keys on it and so on but in
machine learning
the key abstraction is really is the
feature or if you're mapping that to a
database Paradigm is really the column
if you're looking for the popularity of
a server at Discord
you shouldn't have to care that that
table also has
the category of the server or some other
metadata about it
what you really are looking for is I
need the popularity of the server so
we're trying to abstract that away and
have users think of it in terms of
individual features that are keyed off
of individual
individual keys so you know what do I
what do we know about our users what do
we know about our servers what about
know about our user and server
interactions and they could all come
from different tables but we present one
percent a unified
interface to our to our users
uh when the feature storm becomes the
main level of abstraction it makes it a
lot easier to for discovering features
it makes it easier to reuse features
um and by making this access easier our
data scientists are much more likely to
share features because they can pull it
out run some some simple analysis on it
see that it serves its needs and they
use it
we also need very strong support for
real-time features if a great moment
that has happened that we think our
users will love will love we need to
tell them right now we can't tell them
hey yesterday there was this awesome
conversation that we really thought you
would have loved no
same work if there's a bad actor
happening or there's spam happening we
need to detect that as soon as possible
as soon as possible
and we want to be able to again abstract
this away from from our use from our use
a consumer of a feature
shouldn't have to work with the feature
in different ways if it was created in
real time or if it was calculated in
batch
also Discord has has had great success
building on top of bigquery for data
warehouse and bigtable for multiple use
cases and we want to continue we want to
continue with that so therefore it was
very important for us that we were able
to leverage our feature store on top of
bigquery and on top of bigtable
so let's take a little bit of a look at
our at our architecture here
as mentioned we bigquery for our offline
store and bigtable as our online store
we support three different ways of
generating data you have all batch which
could potentially be considered
traditional machine learning features
are calculated periodically daily hourly
in our case we have jobs that are
calculated every 15 minutes
um
uploaded into a feature store and I use
for serving this model is pretty easy to
pretty easy to implement you can use
bigquery you could use black spark or
data flow or any other any other job but
you don't have the real-time aspect of
it
the second version is the Lambda
architecture where you have slow moving
complex features still calculate them
batch in our case using bigquery
uh while now is starting to bring in
real time stream real-time feature
engineering you know when was the last
time the user sent a message what was
the last server they interacted they
interacted with
and we merge them together in the future
store so that a model that needs to make
prediction or an engineer that is
working on a model
they access the data in the same way
they don't have to think about if it's
real time I need to go over here if it's
batch I need to go over here
and the Third Way is the Kappa
architecture where we're now moving
everything to real time
processing
so events are coming in we process them
but in order to bootstrap events where
sometimes the features need longer
history this is specifically true
especially through in the safety domain
where you may have events that are very
infrequent
but you need to react to them very
quickly when they when they come in so
in that case we blunder our feature in
any streaming pipeline where we feed it
using
batch data stored in iceberg Blended in
with the real-time stream coming coming
in Via Pub via Pub sub
this unifies with the feature
calculations are done
and we we avoid this kind of mismatch
we're trying to have one slow moving
version of a feature and then a fast
moving version or feature and training
and training on both of them
um
but again the key when building out this
feature store is that our users
don't have to care about how the future
was generated they may want to know that
this one is updated as soon as an action
happens but in the way that they write
their code and the way that they access
the data it's all Unified
so let's talk a little bit more
specifically about about bigtable
we do take advantage of big tables
multi-sonal feed sonal features for
availability and durability we rely very
heavily on big tables Auto scaling
capabilities we have one cluster that is
used for writing bash data it scales up
heavily when we're doing ingestions and
then we have two read clusters
that I use for the real-time serving and
then we we use big tables like
replication features to get the data to
get the data over
all of our big table data today is read
only as far as like customer interaction
part is as concerned so we could in most
cases recreate recreate the data
latency requirements varies from use
case to use case but big table is really
not a significant source of latency
we're seeing p50s on the order of three
milliseconds and our p99s are typically
around 10 milliseconds but they do Spike
up to 50 milliseconds when we're doing
ingestions we know that we can get this
down lower but frankly it really hasn't
been a priority and bigtable is not a
big source of latency in our system
we take advantage of big tables time to
feature to clear out all data which
saves us the efforts of having jobs to
purge out to purchase steel data
um
and we're currently actively working on
integrating feasts with the fees feature
store and removing our our existing real
table real-time system
onto feast
both bigquery and bigtable have shown
their strengths and we're very excited
to keep working on them as we keep
building out our feature store enamel
capabilities at this card in great
partnership with Google
um
and that is all I have thank you so much
and we are hiring uh you have my name
hit me up on LinkedIn and let's talk
thank you so much
[Applause]
thanks
okay so you heard about these great use
cases and you heard about some
complaints like I'm doing rights it
impacts my read latencies Etc I'm happy
to announce if you want to implement
similar Solutions yourselves
uh things will get better
so this is the chart both Gandalf and
Daniel we're talking about if you run
everything at the same job priority
sometimes if a heavy batch ride or a
heavy batch read comes in you may have
some low latency serving workloads that
will get impacted in this case left side
is before and right side is after this
new feature recall request priorities
when a heavy batch Right comes in if
everyone is running at the same price
everything is running at the same
priority you can see these p99s go to in
this case it's four seconds from your
typical sub 10 millisecond latencies but
with the request priorities which is in
preview now and we'll have a blog post
that will come out tomorrow that'll have
links to sign up for all of these
features that we're talking about here
you'll be able to run those jobs batch
reads or rights at low priority while
you're serving workloads running at high
priority then we'll be able to throttle
spread out de-prioritize those batch
processing jobs that way you will see
the chart on the right hand side where
the impact when those jobs kick in are
fairly noticeable
and if you combine this with auto
scaling things will get even better
because this is a way of absorbing
things by spreading out the loan what if
you have to load more then you can turn
on auto scaling will also combine that
with this
so we're very excited about this this
simplifies a lot of things you don't
have to copy your data out to do heavy
batch processing to other systems so it
simplifies it reduces the cost for you
of course anytime you take the data out
you have the problem of things going out
of sync you want to serve it I have to
publish it materialize it into an online
store like bigtable and this is a very
common flow and you've seen this in a
chart like three minutes ago Gandalf had
that
but you need to have data pipelines it
could be a data proc cluster data flow
Cloud composer there's some sort of ETL
tool that you have to configure or pay
for have a data engineer work with you
so there's a lot of impedance there and
if you want to innovate you want to move
faster so we worked very closely with
the bigquery team
uh to build this directly into bigquery
now you'll be able to write a SQL query
and just export directly from bigquery
there's no tool in the middle uh you
could do this using the apis you can
also use the the UI in there to quickly
convert your SQL code into an ETL job
and this comes with a lot of flexibility
again another feature currently in
preview you will be able to even
schedule these things you could say I
want to run this job every 15 minutes
bigquery has this appends table value
function that will give you things like
what happened since this time so you can
look at deltas and even you know figure
out how to write those Deltas only into
bigtable so it gives you a lot of
flexibility a few clicks you go from a
SQL query into an ETL job
again you will have links to this in the
blog post but since this is such an easy
feature to adopt and play with we also
made it convenient and added a QR code
for you if you want to take a picture of
it you can sign up and it will happily
give you access and I think again with
this feature and more that I can't even
mention because we are out of time a lot
of the things that we discussed these
use cases will become a lot more easy
for you